nous allons devoir inciter les français
à travailler plus longtemps
le gouvernement compte donc reprendre la
proposition du rapport du haut
commissaire qui consiste à instaurer au
dessus de l'âge légal un âge d équilibre
avec un système de bonus malus
le conseil d'orientation des retraites
nous dit qu'il faudrait fixer cet âge à
64 ans en 2025 pour atteindre l'
équilibre à la et c'est là qu'il lâche
fameux mot h pivot qui va avoir une
belle histoire dans les manifestations
la benjamin s j'ai cru voir sur votre
courbe là un pic au mois de décembre est
ce que ça correspond à ce disque ouvre
exactement qu'est ce qui ne passe pas en
fait après le discours d' edouard
philippe
et bien c'est le fait de travailler plus
longtemps autant le fait qu' on passe
finalement de 2,42 régimes spéciaux à un
seul ça c'est quelque chose qui est qui
est plébiscité par les français
autant le fait de travailler plus
longtemps ne passe pas c'est d'ailleurs
ça qu'on va voir derrière se propager
c'est à dire que s'est installée une
perception que tout le monde allait être
perdant sur la durée de la retraite